there's an interesting thing that's
happening why him of course movie
posters all over the place
and there's been I guess I don't for an
artist or who they are
is it a try it's at pro Trump supporter
it's actually yeah there's there's a
piece of artwork that's around a notes
around Los Angeles I don't know if it's
in New York as well in and but it was a
pro Trump artist who was I was getting a
little dig in at me I think and because
I was not a trump supporter right and
you weren't you are now but yeah yeah I
wasn't now yeah yeah so we've all come
around yeah so he mocked up the the why
him poster to be Donald Trump and bring
a France we have it here at Konami and
I'm hugging my candidate there it is but
you know what's interesting this is
supposed to I think this is supposed to
like get you in some way
yeah and it's just it's just kind of
funny it is funny it's funny and you
just look at it you go that's I I
laughed allies it you know it doesn't
matter anything that stimulates an
artist's imagination and creates another
piece of art from something else
it's all fine yeah good yeah yeah no I I
didn't even understand which point of
view it was coming from doesn't it made
me laugh it said of all the people and
all the men that his country could have
voted for why him right it was like well
yeah that's what I was saying - right
right I didn't I'm I was confused at how
that was a pro Trump thing yeah yeah
he's he didn't give it a lot of thought
yeah well maybe did maybe maybe we're
not getting it yeah yeah it's our fault
we're so burned you don't even know your
birth
you